we're going to talk about all of it this
morning as americans are remembering the
life of justice ginsburg republicans and
democrats in congress are fighting over
who will replace her and when the high
court is in mourning with a black cloth
draped over the entrance to its chamber
look at that shot ginsburg's chair is
also draped out of respect for her 27
years on the court
president trump and senate majority
leader mitch mcconnell have vowed to
move
fast using their power to replace her
ben tracy begins our coverage outside
the supreme court ben good morning to
you
when do we expect the president to
announce a nominee
good morning while president trump is
wasting no time he has narrowed down his
list and plans to name a nominee this
week
and you know this election was shaping
up to be a referendum on the president
in his handling
of coronavirus now republicans are
hoping he can reframe that around this
battle
for the court now it says the president
is supposed to fill the seat right and
that's what we're going to do we're
going to fill the scene
at a weekend rally in north carolina
fill that seat became a new rallying cry
this could only happen in north carolina
and president trump made two things
clear
he will quickly nominate a new justice
and it will be a woman
it will be a woman a very talented very
brilliant woman
cbs news has learned two of the top
contenders are u.s court of appeals
judges
amy coney barrett and barbara lagoa the
48-year-old barrett is a favorite of
religious conservatives for her
anti-abortion views
she clerked for former justice antonin
scalia and
president trump considered her to
replace justice kennedy when he retired
well she's very highly respected i can
say that lagoa is 52 and has a longer
judicial record
she is also a conservative as well as a
first generation cuban american from the
key swing state of florida
she was confirmed to the court of
appeals with bipartisan support
she's an extraordinary person i've heard
incredible things about her i don't know
her
she's hispanic and highly respected
miami
to jam this nomination through the
senate is just an
exercise in raw political power on
sunday former vice president joe biden
said he expected president trump to
nominate someone
but appealed the republican senators
imploring them not to vote on a nominee
before the november election don't go
there
uphold your constitutional duty your
conscience
let the people speak now biden says if
he wins in november then president
trump's nominee should be withdrawn in
the meantime this is
firing up both sides democrats raising
record sums of money about 100 million
dollars
just since friday and the trump campaign
is now selling
fill that seat t-shirts on its website
anthony
ben thank you